Oh guys we are so fucking excited it's
the 10 year anniversary of nostalgia
critic who or not but because of that we
have to watch and well usually when I do
like a newer movie I try to have a
nostalgic connection if possible but so
many people want us to see Norma the
Norris so we're finally going to do that
one we are Jessie drugs job Oh Richard I
wish we're watching that
okay um god we don't want to do this oh
we have to well I would know yeah no
overweight it's the fourth animated
Titanic movie I don't think this movie
is gonna be worthy of the story this
whole movie is like first draft is nice
I kicked and they did not at Christmas
put it in normal the north any last
words for you how is it a bear can talk
with the seal can't well then why'd you
ask if there's any last word yeah don't
identify with your victims that's also
good for Rob Schneider don't identify
with your victims you won't want to make
any more movies this looks like like a
bad commercial like that one of these
bears is going to pull out toilet paper
any second of me like didn't you either
go I didn't ask for this what is wrong
with you yes gonna say is that's a hard
to see why Rob Schneider picked us know
every line is like what's wrong with me
don't believe the hater to finally a
positive message for me it looks like
you know how when you see a good
animated film is like well you're in a
different world I just feel like I'm in
a program it was really good a green
saver she looks like this cute little
animated gifts from back like in the
early 2000 like a dancing journey
what am i watching killer whale should
not be sexy that is a sin against nature
oh my god antic talking bear and that's
whole hey they're too pedantic talking
better
Superman used to live there but they
father shame Norman the North what nope
picked up the house and moved away she
looks like one of those little porcelain
dolls that's going to eat you in your
nightmares they all look like you know
this movie killed more kids than choking
hazards and toys actually this film
itself is a choking hazard a number of
toddlers tried to swallow their own
tongues while watching
ha ha ha french-canadian Joe I gotta
admit I don't hear those often plus one
for originality minus three for not
being fun kid you don't need to sit that
close to the screen those glasses should
do the fuckin trust you should be able
to see on the moon she's going to be
legally blind by the time 2:15 we're
gonna be legally blind by the time his
movies over I'd pay good money know if
they run into the iron giants head
somewhere in there he completely like
laser blasts the polar bear and then we
follow his head back and it turns out it
was all akkad this entire giant people
at last Sherman from Peabody and Sherman
at a sex change
ha ha ha young you have a feeling you
never feel either feeling good for them
yeah good really good for them this is
covera we are the Sims had better
animation and then you know I'm sorry I
pulling for a second what's happened I
don't know that guy is a stereotype I
just don't know what yeah don't know why
yeah free if I get it right then I'll be
contributing to that stereotypes I don't
want to get this movie so bad it can't
even be offensive because it doesn't
even know how if everything in this
movie looks like it wants to eat me
except the actual animal who would want
to eat me
seeing lemmings because this is where we
are as a species right now we're not
we're seeing again it's like the
movement of this guy could be funny is
like they're under something but they're
not talented they need to be talented to
make this work this movie sucks sorry
mr. green I was just keeping a real gun
there's only norm now oh what a shock
something stupid happening so dancing
that's like but he's a guy with their
gun why are there prove already to be
over I have canceled one and club it
ready I swear she's a cancer woman did
you hear that
I heard cancer focus honestly my ears
stopped functioning
they've been tuning this movie out all I
hear whenever these people open their
mouths is just you know let's just
imagine that we didn't turn the sound on
would you be able to follow this story
like Lion King Beauty and the Beast
Aladdin you know you'd be able to follow
it but it's like this I would have no
idea what's going on every sound I make
if this movie is kinda like the no faces
peered into eight undergoing more Tina
from Bob's Burgers
and then occasionally when it gets
really creepy ha ha ha sometimes I wish
she wasn't so good at her job if it
meant she got to spend more time with me
oh this Thomas Christ you just know at
this point this is playing to an empty
house it's like two theater attendants
making out in the back and even they are
getting discussed as like an I better
move in to do this yeah they justify me
because they think his name is Norma and
his last names the north is Albert no I
got it this is one of those fake
trailers that plays the poor Tropic
Thunder this isn't a real movie it would
be amazing event the very end of it Andy
Kaufman just stepside I was alive the
whole time I was alive this is all one
big punk thank you very much shit I
would call this the greatest movie ever
made in bet he's rolling 211 I would
have paid good money they had to mocap
this entire movie get the SAO schneider
met her jeans must have beat the shit
out of her husband's jeans because good
god that's like identical bad she is
just so quickly invested it's almost
like they barely got chance to know each
other it's like we're besties Malick
when does that happen
I don't even know your last name
honestly I had a talking polar bear
suddenly show up and be like hey let's
be friends I'd be like okay I've had the
voice of Rob Schneider well no then I
kick it in the crotch do it I can't do
it I was there I'm there I think god I
hope so
ha ha ha remember where they said he was
a poet and he did poetry I love how that
all worked into his character and story
like he said he was a poet and then he
danced that that tied together very well
evils MC square because deke cuz when we
geek fight that like oh my god gotta put
it on the wall movie started getting
them those not very good from the start
the perfect number
hey isn't it cool that they had like
this love interest who did so much yeah
there's like so many things that started
then they got shelled off it was like I
am done they were in the movie
time to go back and write my poetry Rob
Schneider oh yeah they actually abandon
up there Oh directed everything needs to
be in quotes
screenplay by produced by ah sock sock
Oh God
ah ah what to point all this stupid shit
stupid shit
it's about this no no it's about this
stupid shit oh ah no sir I didn't like
it just was clearly draft one that's a
separate there's no rewrite just the
first thing they wrote the worsen is in
my top 10 no but that might be my top 15
there's an almost confidence to it to
have like all your areas no para todo
America like food fight or something
like that where there really is no comma
Christmas tree or whatever where there
really is no condom all you did was
merely say well compared to rock bottom
yeah this is the free we have a rock
bottom I would put top 15 maybe top 30
this has no right being in the cinema
none this is a direct-to-dvd like and
not even that and this should be in the
bargain direct to the bargain bin DVD so
okay that's that's about it guys uh
bad don't go see it fuck you for making
me watch that bye
you